the Creator economy is going to double
in the next 5 years 2.6 billion monthly
active users on YouTube entrepreneurs
that approach YouTube are not going to
commit to content creation they're going
to commit to building a media
company if you're talking to an
entrepreneur business owner here is like
what do you predict in the future will
there be a lot more of us and and you
know where is it moving to so if you
were going to really invest I think it's
wise to say is it worth investing in
content is it worth investing in YouTube
is it worth investing in social media is
is it going growing bigger is it
plateaued is it on the decline you
probably don't want to open up a chain
store for renting physical DVDs and VHS
tapes as Blockbuster is rapidly closing
stores and Netflix is taking over and
now there's only one blockbuster left
and it's an epic story because
Blockbuster had a chance to buy Netflix
passed on the opportunity because they
didn't see where the trend was going
they didn't see where the next thing was
going so what's the data tell us well
Goldman Sachs
research released an article Based on
data predicting that the Creator economy
the total addressable Market is going to
double in the next 5 years this is
pretty wild because when you think about
the creater economy already and that for
the business owner they're like what
does that even mean well this
is independent content creators starting
channels across social media platforms
and how much money are they generating
how
much what kind of businesses are they
building but also what the creater
economy would be is there's creater
economy startups you think of a company
like Adobe the video editing software
Jelly smack which repurposes content for
creators and monetizes across platforms
carrot which is a credit card that your
credit line is based off your follower
account and other metrics because
traditional lending doesn't understand
creators as much and so
When anybody looks at the amount of
money in the system essentially the
total addressable Market about $250
billion right now and then sees that
it's estimated to be about half a
trillion in the next few years and then
observes how crazy it is right now how
2.6 billion monthly active users on
YouTube 2.7 billion monthly active users
on YouTube how many Creator startups
like think media are hiring people
maturing
uh how many small midsize and large
craters there are how much money there
is and what's shocking about that half a
trillion dollar industry over the next
few years is that's not
calculating a lot of our customer base a
lot of the people who follow us are real
estate agents loan officers service
providers professionals experts coaches
course creators as well as
DIY uh home organization Frugal Living
creators cooking channels mothers that
can actually just monetize their content
itself but we're looking about the whole
entrepreneur side or service provider
side where real estate agents start a
YouTube channel and increase their
transactions per month by 100% 200% 300%
while real estate here in the US is
being devastated creators that are
pivoting and starting to embrace social
media and YouTube or rather business
owners entrepreneurs agents are not only
protecting and surviving through a
recession but thriving in a recession as
the housing market is frozen here um
because they're embracing New Media so
on to simplify what I'm suggesting is
that if it's already creating so much
prosperity and so much impact right now
and the data and Trends is showing us
that it's going to key word double in
the next 5 years then investing in
content creation and starting a YouTube
channel is a really good is a good
investment and and it would not just be
uh like I hope this works it would be
like oh yeah there's real data to
support that the final thing I would say
in answer to your question is what's
changed over the last 5 10 years on
YouTube there's certainly a lot of
dragons we need to slay a lot of giants
we need to slay one is of course
competition is rising the opportunity is
very real and growing and doubling but
there's more people that are aware of
that opportunity and so I think that 5
10 years ago on YouTube you could
succeed if you were playing
checkers in a 2023 2024 World you're not
going to succeed unless you're playing
chess what does that mean it means that
man you got to learn the skills you have
to develop a strategy you got to be
strategic with your content you just
can't cavalierly lob out some content
not be thoughtful about the title not be
thoughtful about how it's packaged not
be thoughtful about the thumbnail not
not mastering the strategies of best
practices of YouTube I think that the
smartest entrepreneurs that approach
YouTube are not going to commit to
content creation they're going to commit
to building a media company we're
seeing that smart entrepreneurs aren't
like I'm not going to start creating
content I'm basically going to open up a
division like they that the modern
marketing is you used to put dollars and
maybe still do a behind whatever your
advertising was traditional billboard
paperclick magazine
newspaper direct mail and by the and if
that stuff's still working and you're
tracking it then by all means in fact
those will be even bigger opportunities
as some people forget about some of
these mediums however
dollar for
dooll rather than just thinking how do I
create content with my smartphone it's
who can I hire there's a good book
called who not how by Dan Sullivan and
Benjamin Hardy and and it's actually who
is going to run the media Department
that is going to help me embrace New
Media rather than how am I going to
start creating content I'm already too
busy so smart business owners aren't
just going to be like I'm going to start
creating a few pieces of content they're
going to say oh I'm going to build a
media company inside of my company
that's basically a division that is
going to embrace this not as a six-month
Trend but as a lifestyle and critical
component of successful businesses over
the next five years why this whole thing
is doubling and so I think it's about
Skilling up it's about getting educated
it's about being
strategic and it's about learning these
new mediums and it's about I'm bullish
on YouTube it's also Based on data it's
the number one video platform I really
think it should be your kind of home
base and a place of pillar content but I
think it's also important that we don't
become romantic about any of these
things my company this is sh might shock
a few people and seem intimidating you
don't start here but we post 350 pieces
of content a
week um wow and that's a team that's a
system that's a routine by the way and
I've had I have more lifestyle more
peace of mind more time with my
one-year-old and three-year-old than
I've ever had as well so it's not just
about grit and hustle that's important
in certain Seasons it's not just about
an intense season of maybe sacrificing a
lot of people listening to this need to
go into that season because they've got
a learning curve that they need to
shorten and catch up on to embrace some
of these things but on the other side of
learning leveling
up the pain before the prosperity of
hiring like I don't even know this like
the the skill Gap the education Gap but
but you got an admin person maybe a
videographer maybe a video editor you've
got you've got the system built for how
content is being produced not only is
there more leads client sales doubling
of your company more Revenue waiting for
you on the other side of building this
but there's also more peace of mind
Lifestyle on the other side as well
because social media will work for you
if you learn how to work it and what
back to not being romantic our 350
pieces of content I'm not just posting
on YouTube we're posting two videos a
day on Tik Tok we're posting two
Instagram reals a day which also go to
Facebook reels um we are posting YouTube
shorts we're on multiple YouTube
channels um and if a new platform
emerges we're exploring that as well
when you're aware of what your offer is
and who you're who you can add value to
and basically who do you help and how do
you help them there's no reason why you
shouldn't be on threads people go oh it
dropped
you know
75% after the buzz wore off and you're
like well sure but but if it was 100
million people engaged and it dropped
75% still
25 million people the
somewhat
cynical and headline
reading novice goes oh look threads is
dead the wise tactician and strategist
says 25 million people is still a pretty
radical group that I could reach with my
message my product my service and so
embracing the The
Undefeated and provable thesis that
social media is the greatest way it's
the most affordable way to reach the
billions of people that are on the
internet right now because most of us
don't have money for a Super Bowl
commercial or for traditional
media I think you accept that thesis and
then you just put in the grit work and
learnings necessary to back it up
multiplied by time and some people
listening to this podcast are going to
be shocked by what they're able to build
and how big they're able to grow their
company or how they're able to prect
their company in famine like Joseph
storing away grain for the next seven
years learning a new skill set so that
when the famine hits you're ready you
better learn to swim now so that when
the world gets flooded you don't drown
and so you better build your Ark now so
that when the flood comes you're
prepared for it and so I think those
that are paying attention to these
shifts in the media landscape and
business landscape are going to be happy
that they did because everyone's saying
ah it's not going to rain and uh once it
starts to you're like I was probably
smart I was building a boat in the
desert uh because you're ready with this
new media skill set that is so essential
if you enjoy this podcast and are ready
for some deep dive YouTube strategy just
go to think masterclass.com to get
access to my 1our OnDemand YouTube
strategy class you'll be looking over my
shoulder as I share my best tips and you
can watch it on Demand right now at
think masterclass.com